ومن قلب الحدث من امام الاستاد معنى موفد
العربيه فهد الشهري لينقل لنا الاجواء من
هناك فهد تفضل
[موسيقى]
منداليات تدفق الجمهور من قبل اربع ساعات
من الثامنه صباحا للملعب حيث فتحت الابواب
في الساعه 9:00 حضور جمهور كبير اعتقد ان
الملعب الجميل ملعب لوسيل اللي خلفنا راح
يكون ممتلئ بالكامل من الجماهير السعوديه
وايضا الجماهير الارجنتينيه
بينما تنقل لنا الاجواء
اي نعم عصام هذا حضور الجمهور الجمهور زي
ما تشوفين لازال يحضر ملعب
في اجواء الجماهريه تشاهد الرقصات
المختلفه تشاهد التحديات شاهد الى الجمهور
اللي يحمل كاس العالم شاهد الجمهور اللي
يحمل نجوم المختلفه في المنتخبين اللي
يحمل الارجنتين اللي يحمل صوره ليونيل
ميسي السعودي اللي يحمل صوره سالم الدوسري
تبادل التحديات تبادل
الجميله اللي راح ايضا يحتضن ايضا نهائي
كاس العالم في قطر 2002 وعشرين الجمهور
السعوديه حضر ومكه المتفائل بمنتخبه يثق
في ان شاء الله انه يقدم مستوى
مرشح منتخب قوي زي المنتخب الارجنتيني ما
يسوى طيب على كلن يبدا ان هناك تقطع
بالصوت خلينا نركز الصوره حتى يثبت الصوت
فهد باختصار تشكيله المنتخب الاخضر خبرنا
نعم عصام عصام تشكيله المنتخب الاخضر نزلت
قبل الوقت قليل كانت نفس التشكيله اللي
خاضها السيد هرفي رونالد في الرياض امام
المنتخب الكرواتي مع تغيير في قلب الدفاع
حسان تمبكتي بديلا العامري بجانب وهمم علي
البليهي بالاطراف سعود عبد الحميد وياسر
الشهراني
عبد الله المالكي محمد كانه في خط الوسط
سلمان الفرج في راس البركان وسالم الدوسري
وفي الامام المهاجم صالح الشهري تشكيله
المنتخب جديده تشكيله ما خاف فيها اي
مباراه
في المباريات الوديه نتمنى انه تحقيق
المطلوب طبعا فهد السؤال الاخير باختصار
الحضور الرسمي
[موسيقى]
الحضور الجماهيري نعم يحدد ويقدر بعدد
15000 مشجع سعودي البقيه كلهم يا مستمتعين
يا ايضا جمهور الارجنتيني كبير جدا
في هذه المباراه ميسون نبغى ناخذ بس رايي
شويه للمشجعين السعوديين قبل المباراه
ممكن دقيقه حياك الله
المباراه خلاص على الابواب عطني شعورك
والله نتمنى ان يقدم المنتخب الاداه اللي
همم يتامى كل الجمهور
الاكثر في مباراه مثلا زي الارجنتين
الافضل انك همم اقلها الاداء افضل من اكثر
من النتيجه لان همم باذن الله يعني
المجموعه في امل انا باذن
[موسيقى]
حياك الله الله يحييك مرتبك والله ناوي في
خوف في خوف قدام تلعب قدام الارجنتين قدام
ميسي افضل لاعب في العالم طبيعي الخوف لكن
ان شاء الله نقول اول نص ساعه اذا مرت
بالتعادل نقول ان شاء الله نقدر في
المباراه نقدر باذن الله
في المنتخب السعودي